course it is digital it means the money  can be programmed to be spent in any way  in which the central bank or the  government decides so one of my  particular concerns is the world  economic Forum because they're talking  about implementing a carbon allowance  now this means each individual will be  given a certain amount of um whether  it's credit or whatever it is carbon  that they are allowed to Emit and how do  they Implement that through a central  bank digital currency so if I buy too  many plane tickets or if I buy too much  meat because those things are all  supposedly very bad for the environment  my money when I go to fill up my car  could then be declined